so this time let's see if I can get this
to work okay last time as you recall we
looked at strategies that companies can
use to avoid or minimize or mitigate
biodiversity risks and we talked a lot
about biodiversity offsetting and the
concept of net positive impact and then
we looked at the opportunity side and
how you can use some of these emerging
payment for ecosystem service schemes to
to add business value either to generate
new revenue or to improve business
reputation and other or reduce costs for
example what I'd like to talk about in
this last lecture on implications of
teeb for businesses what can we expect
from companies in terms of voluntary
action and also when you reach the
limits of voluntary action what what
kind of other instruments do we have
what other mechanisms or incentives can
we consider to stimulate more business
action to conserve biodiversity and
deliver ecosystem services and I'll
start as usual with the voluntary side
and in the team for business report we
identified a number of things that
businesses could do on their own without
necessarily waiting for other people to
to help them or give them incentives or
guidance or constraints and those can be
boiled down or I want to focus on these
these five in particular and some of
these we've covered already and
discussed in the previous lectures so
what I'm going to talk a little bit
about is targets and how companies set
those and give an example and then I'm
going to come back to the last point
which is market-friendly or business
friendly environmental policy my sense
is that we've already discussed in the
previous lectures numbers 2 3 and 4 that
is measure value and report your
footprint using and improving tools for
biodiversity management and building
biodiversity business so
I'll focus on one and five and I've
already mentioned some examples of
companies that have set what seemed like
ambitious or sometimes heroic or maybe
aspirational targets with respect to
biodiversity and other ecosystem
services and we can see this pretty much
across the board in in every major
economy and many well-known brands where
companies are making commitments on a
voluntary basis that they don't have to
do and that can sometimes be a stimulus
to to action inside the company and
increased scrutiny from outside the
company and just to give a few examples
here that I selected from the company
websites over the last couple of years a
BC Hydro is a hydroelectric power
generator based in British Columbia in
Canada and they have set themselves a
rather incredible target in my view of
no net incremental environmental impact
which is interesting because it implies
that they're going to be looking at all
types of ecosystem impacts or
environmental impacts and the net
incremental are interesting words to use
in a target as well because they imply
that they're going to be looking at
pluses and minuses credits and debits
and using this kind of net positive
impact approach coca-cola has a somewhat
narrower target and that is to basically
leave watersheds as in his good
condition as they found them and they
talk about safely returning to
communities and to nature an amount of
water equivalent to what they use and
it's interesting here to me that they
talk about the amount of water they
aren't talking about the quality of
water and maybe that's recognition that
they're not sure that they can meet that
quality goal the downand group with
which I've I've worked for several years
wants to go for carbon neutrality they
don't have to do this so they're looking
at voluntary offsets and voluntary
mitigation efforts and they're seeing
this essentially as a branding action
many of their competitors put little
labels on their plastic bottles of
mineral water claiming that they are
carbon neutral and they want to be part
of that they don't want to be left
behind by their their competitors and I
think they are on target to achieve that
initial goal of carbon neutrality for
Evian and as I may have mentioned a big
part of their strategy is investing in
wetland restoration and wetland
conservation particularly planting
mangroves around the world in the
tropics sometimes in countries where
they have big operations like Indonesia
or Mexico but sometimes in countries
where they don't such as India and in
Senegal and it's been interesting from a
biodiversity perspective because of
course mangroves have a key role to play
in protecting coastlines and is fish
nurseries and as a source of food and
fuel for local communities and there are
many other examples but what I want to
focus on today is is Sony and this was
new to me about a year ago and I hadn't
realized that Sony had made such a
commitment but their claim is that by
2050 they will have zero environmental
footprint that's an extraordinary claim
for a large multinational manufacturing
distribution and marketing company to
make and I hadn't heard of it before as
anyone here heard of Sony's target no
because it makes me wonder how feasible
they think it is to achieve this target
but they certainly have said it it's on
their website you can find it you have
to dig a bit but they intend to have
zero footprint with respect to climate
change the use of natural resources
promoting biodiversity and controlling
chemical substances
and we know because of the nature of
their activities that they cannot
achieve that without some kind of
offsetting or compensatory action so it
implies and they're already starting
this with climate change that they're
going to have to invest quite
substantially in resource conservation
climate mitigation actions outside their
operations and biodiversity offsets
presumably if they're going to have any
chance of achieving this target quite
sensibly they intend to look across the
product life cycle so they're not just
looking at their own manufacturing
operations but also their procurement of
raw materials as well as the
distribution of their their products and
the ultimate destination of those
products again they have time bound
milestones to achieve this target they
hope to achieve it by 2050 and then
they're back casting to try and figure
out what they can deliver in the interim
I wasn't able to get from them specific
quantitative targets what are they going
to achieve by 2015 or by 2020 and again
i think that is suggestive of the fact
that they're a little uncertain about
what they can deliver and how quickly
but they've done their homework and and
i've found this of some other companies
as well they've tried to understand what
the links are between their activities
and biodiversity and all of these slides
are from a presentation that the company
made at the 10th conference of the
parties of the the CBD last year in
Japan so they're going public with this
and they're pretty clear about what they
need to do about it looking not just a
direct impacts but also their indirect
impacts and I was struck by a contrast
between how sophisticated they are with
respect to reducing materials use
reducing weight using more
environmentally friendly materials
recycling and so on a lot of things that
they do with respect to their own
operations that are fully integrated
into the
products and yet when you look and I
should be happy with this especially
because they're making a contribution to
my new employer so I'm it's always good
news when I look on the other hand at
their biodiversity impacts over their
biodiversity actions they're much less
well connected to their operations I
think this is typical of a lot of
companies they can see clearly how they
need to address their energy use or
their materials consumption in their
manufacturing or increased recycling of
waste materials but they're often add a
little bit of a loss about what to do on
the biodiversity front just as they have
trouble measuring their in their impacts
on biodiversity and finding appropriate
indicators many companies struggle to
find appropriate investments or
appropriate activities to support that
relate to biodiversity and also relate
to their own operations and it tends to
make their biodiversity actions look
more like charitable disconnected
activities compared to some of their
other environmental actions it's not to
discount the value of those investments
but it suggests to me that many
companies particularly manufacturing
companies that are a bit remote from
direct footprints on on ecosystems
sometimes find it difficult to to
identify appropriate actions that they
can take and as a result you see a lot
of tree planting around manufacturing
facilities or you see contributions to
conservation organizations NGOs in
completely other different parts of the
world that have no no link whatsoever
with their their production activities
so those are just some some ideas and
one example of what companies can do on
a voluntary basis and some of the the
constraints that they face in addressing
biodiversity footprint in particular i
should probably go back to one other
example Unilever few months ago came out
with a sustainable living plan and their
approach to this is really to focus on
raw
supply and on certification of the
sustainability of those raw materials I
think it's easier here for an
agricultural well an agricultural
processing and food processing company
to identify the links with biodiversity
because things like grains and fiber and
dairy are so central to their their
activities and fish for example again
very heroic goals are they going to
actually be able to find enough
sustainably produced material to meet
one hundred percent of their needs by
2020 it's not obvious there's real
difficulties in providing enough of the
certified timber for example to meet the
potential demand and many people in the
trade will say well we'd love to buy the
stuff is just not available so we buy
the the regular okay I want to talk a
little bit about more the regulatory
side and what business can do in terms
of helping to develop market-friendly
environmental policies that is to say
policies that support biodiversity
conservation but that also help reduce
costs or increase profits and another
way to put that is to try and identify
what kind of regulatory reforms are most
efficient or effective in stimulating
business action and I think it's useful
here to step back and remind ourselves
of what's the context for this and what
have has been the history of
environmental policy particularly
respect to biodiversity and ecosystems
and it's quite complex but I think it's
fair to say that an awful lot of that
existing policy framework is focused on
doing no harm reducing harm or you know
trying to minimize habitat
disturbance and conversion trying to
ensure that resource management is more
sustainable reducing pollution trying to
ensure that benefits are shared
equitably not just genetic resources but
other resources and trying to raise more
money and these are the kind of things
that we've been hearing from the
environmental community for years and
years and they're not necessarily
directly relevant or translatable to the
business world and that's been a bit of
a problem and we've seen in particular a
huge emphasis on a kind of command and
control or an effort to constrain
resource use as a way of protecting
biodiversity and so the most
conventional or classic approach is more
protected areas and we've seen a huge
growth in protected areas around the
world and despite that last year again
we saw a call for more protected areas
and this is fine and they do play a role
in biodiversity conservation but we also
know that they're hugely difficult to
finance and that's partly because they
rely very heavily on public funding for
the most part and essentially they're
taking resources out of productive use
or out of econ out of market use but
without any clear mechanism to generate
funding for that other than tax revenue
and protected areas have other problems
as we know they impose as we saw last
time large opportunity costs on local
populations and this is a case that was
carried out by a colleague of mine in
Uganda looking at the impacts of
protected areas on local resource uses
and the the loss of economic production
opportunities to local communities as a
result of the creation of the protected
area loss of pasture wildlife damage to
farms because you have more wildlife if
you have a protected area and other
restrictions on resource use and on the
other side of the ledger there's not
enough revenue coming in
whether it's from tourism or from the
state to make up that gap I think partly
in response to frustration with the the
traditional approaches whether those are
protected areas or technology
constraints for example the limits on
the kind of nets you can use for fishing
or when you can go fishing these are all
useful instruments but they often are
working against the tide of of economic
pressure and they are they're not
working with the grain of economic
incentives and so a different approach
that people have been trying to develop
in the last I guess 10 or 20 years is to
mobilize economic incentives to make it
more profitable to do the right thing
less profitable to do the wrong thing
and that starts very often with trying
to unpick subsidies that are driving
unsustainable resource use and we've
seen any number of official documents
and unofficial documents that talk about
how we can generate more resources for
biodiversity conservation by using
intelligent market-based or market
oriented economic incentives and teeb
likewise talks quite a lot not just
about what our ecosystem values and how
do we quantify and measure those but
also how do we capture those values how
do we realize them and make them real in
in monetary terms to consumers and
producers and just to liven things up a
little bit I wanted to get a sense of
from people in the room as what's your
take on that because I realized that its
controversial and that there are many
people particularly in the environmental
community who are uncomfortable with
this approach to using economic
incentives they're uncomfortable with
putting a price on natural resources
we've seen this for example in the
Global Water Forum year after year the
idea of putting a price on water is
is considered an athlon too many people
so I'm curious to know in this room
given that sometimes people think that
certain aspects of nature our price
lists or should be priceless I'd like
people here to give me to volunteer give
me their view on under what conditions
if ever should nature have a price and
hoping that somebody will take a crack
at that I should probably move on a
little bit and continue I appreciate the
different perspectives on pricing nature
and commodification of nature and I
think you've put your finger on a lot of
the the concerns that people have and
you've also made it you know reinforced
in my mind the the fact that this is not
a resolved issue that there's still the
boundaries of what's appropriate and
under what conditions still need to be
discussed and and figured out having
said that the big global institutions
and most of the scientific community
continue to push this line and you see
it again and again in some of the
seminal reports such as the millennium
ecosystem assessment came out 2005
talking about not just valuation but
integrating those values into economic
decision-making reforming subsidies
paying for ecosystem services reducing
unsustainable consumption and using a
variety of economic instruments to try
and promote more conservation and
restoration and it might be helpful to
think a little bit about what does that
mean in practice what are we actually
talking about if you boil it down
essentially we're comparing different
practices different types of production
different types of consumption some are
more damaging than others and very
simply what we want to do is to increase
the costs of the unsustainable practice
and decrease the costs of the more
sustainable models
and on the flip side we want to reduce
the benefits of the unsustainable
practice and increase the economic
benefits of the the more sustainable
choice and there are a range of
different mechanisms that we can use in
those four different boxes to try and
achieve those increases or decreases in
costs and benefits you're probably
familiar with the millennium ecosystem
assessment and it's categorization of
different ecosystem services and the way
they grouped them into enhanced degraded
and mixed and the point that they made
in that report that the only ecosystem
services that were enhanced as far as
they could tell were the ones related
mainly to commodity production for human
needs as well as carbon sequestration
and I think that was mainly because of
forest growth in the temperate regions
but that most other ecosystem services
they identified were in decline and last
time we talked a little bit about
payments for ecosystem services which I
sometimes like to describe as fixing
markets you have an existing commodity
its traded widely whether it's an
agricultural commodity commercial fish
timber or pulp but those markets are not
reflecting all of the ecosystem service
values all the environmental values
associated with the production of those
Goods and so we have a range of
instruments for fixing markets and we
talked a little bit about that last time
in particular the concept of defining
sustainability standards turning those
into a certification and labeling scheme
ensuring the third-party verification of
producers adherence to those standards
but what I want to talk a little bit
more about now is creating markets so
not just what do you do about the things
that are already traded and where we can
improve practices but what do you do
when you have an ecosystem service that
essentially is completely invisible from
a market perspective and until recently
that was the case with carbon of course
it's still the case largely with genetic
material although there's some few
trades that we can see around
bioprospecting in most countries it's
still true with respect to water quality
and in some cases just raw water water
quantity and i've added as you can see
habitat restoration down at the bottom
because that again is a fairly recent
case except in the US where there's been
some progress in a few other countries
carbon is the best-known of these and
probably the the largest market that to
have emerged just in the last few years
and it's striking how quickly that took
off mainly because of action by european
governments so they established the
emissions trading scheme entered into
force i think in 2005 and within a few
years after that you had transactions in
in the order of a hundred billion u.s.
dollars alongside that we had the Clean
Development Mechanism under the Kyoto
Protocol much smaller but still
generating some significant financial
flows and if you add that up over the
few years you're looking at over 300
billion dollars that wasn't going into
anything like this before and was now
going into energy conservation emission
reductions forest carbon offsets and a
range of other activities of which
almost 80 billion dollars was from annex
1 countries that is to say developed
countries to the developing countries
that we're offering climate mitigation
credits now there are all kinds of
problems with this market as we know it
has been extremely volatile the
Europeans didn't always get the
allocation of quotas right and so prices
went all over the place and speculators
some of them got burned we don't really
care about the speculators but we do
care perhaps about the environmental
effectiveness of the scheme and if you
don't have
some certainty about the the value of
your your quota you can easily
understand that businesses are not going
to invest in them they've also been
concerns about the allocation of Clean
Development Finance the Clean
Development Mechanism is sometimes
called the China Development Mechanism
because so much of that money went into
China for particularly for the
destruction of certain industrial gases
and there have been concerns about the
types of projects that have been used to
generate carbon credits and in
particular the very low amount of
funding that went into forestry and
agriculture and related for ecosystem
friendly mitigation activities on the
voluntary side there's been perhaps more
success at generating resources for
forest restoration forest conservation
it's a completely different scale of
course I mean here you've got a table
for the showing the investments in
forest carbon in particular and you
remember from the previous slide it was
about 1% of the CDM total and that
corresponds to the 6 million in 2010 in
this table but in contrast we have
rather more substantial resources as i
said in the voluntary market these are
people who do not have a legal
requirement to mitigate their greenhouse
gas emissions or to achieve any climate
change targets but they for whatever
reason have decided that they wish to do
so and are prepared to pay for that and
a lot of this in fact is red money just
within the last couple of years there's
been growing interest in in financing
red projects but a more conventional
type of forest carbon project and you've
probably studied this is this example
from Tanzania where investors
find some degraded land usually
previously cultivated agricultural land
they acquire a lease and plants in this
case as in many other cases exotic
species that grow fast and can lock up a
lot of carbon quite quickly and they
managed to push it through the very
arduous permitting system that is the
Clean Development Mechanism or the
voluntary carbon standard in order to
get credits and very often they
supplement the value of those carbon
credits as you know with other co
benefits such as in this case telephone
poles furniture pallets for shipping and
so on and one of the main concerns in
Tanzania as in many other countries has
been the social impacts of these forest
carbon projects and the idea that by
bringing in foreign investment you may
be essentially having the same effect as
a conventional protected area you're
putting a fence around the place armed
guards keeping people out there losing
access to resources that they previously
enjoyed for the benefit of polluters in
in the north and I think in in this
respect a lot of these environmental
markets are not so different from
conventional markets in the sense that
you have different interest groups
looking for different outcomes so this
is a case study from Indonesia that
compared the perspective of local
communities logging industries local
government national government and the
international community with respect to
three different land use options and the
authors discovered in this case that
while it might make more sense in
economic terms in net present value
terms to go with the conservation option
and that was certainly the perspective
from the local communities from the
perspective of the logging industry it
was much better to cut the trees down no
surprise this is
just confirming sort of the intuition
that we would have and I think you can
draw an analogy with a carbon market or
indeed with some other ecosystem service
markets there might be cases where for
the local community the best option is
the status quo which includes some
unsustainable resource use and you could
substitute the conservation banking
industry or the carbon investment
industry for the logging industry very
often their interests are not going to
be aligned and we have some work to do
to try and find ways to align those
interests better and that leads me to
Wall Street because I thought my last
lecture here I five and I was intrigued
by this phenomena and went down to visit
liberty park or Zuccotti Park whatever
you want to call it over the weekend and
I was struck by the emphasis there on
the equity issues but no consideration
no discussion that I could see or very
little of the environmental issues and
I'm wondering if they're people here who
have thoughts on what how do these
things relate to each other right is
there some Occupy Wall Street's very
concerned very focused on inequity in
American society in capitalism generally
about the rich not pulling their weight
not paying their fair share of taxes and
I'm wondering if there are any opinions
or views here on what does this have to
do with biodiversity if you were to go
yourself to New York or to the Occupy
Wall Street events here in new haven for
that matter what would you say about
biodiversity and ecosystems what does it
have to do with that there's it's
there's good research for example on the
effect of inequality on health outcomes
in many countries there's pretty good
research on the effect of inequality on
product
growth and in some countries and there
are a few studies that look at the
relation between inequality and and
biodiversity loss but I think they're a
little bit tenuous I'd haven't seen the
particular paper you're referring to but
it's not a it's not a well-researched
area it's not like I mean it would be
nice to be able to write on a t-shirt
inequality destroys the earth but we're
we don't really know that and I think it
maybe that's something that could be of
interest for as a research agenda people
who want to pursue this try and
understand what are the links between
inequality and natural resource use does
it make it easier or harder to to find
solutions or does it exacerbate the
problem in some way and can we measure
that that's it's not so straightforward
this example that I referred to earlier
is suggestive but it simply is pointing
out the fact that incentives are
different among different groups it's
not saying that if there was somehow
more equality in Indonesia there would
be you know more conservation that's a
hypothesis one might draw out of the
study but it's not a proof of that
anyways it's an interesting question to
think about coming back to to carbon
markets and I flagged them because they
are as I said one of the the biggest
most well integrated global
environmental markets created within the
last few years I think we can identify a
number of lessons that come out of that
for any kind of market creation for
ecosystem services one we've talked a
lot about is the issue of currency what
is it you're trading how do you measure
that secondly once you've defined what
it is you're going to trade what is the
ecosystem service that you're pricing
and transferring what are the approved
methodologies or recognized means of
delivering that
put that product if you're turning an
ecosystem service into a tradable
commodity you need some way for people
to say yes that is a legitimate way to
produce that commodity and in the carbon
market there are certain things you can
do that are recognized as delivering a
carbon credit and many other things that
people would like to do that they think
would generate a carbon credit but
they're not yet approved and you have to
go through a review process to get your
methodology approved as we discovered
with with the mangrove restoration
project with with Dan and that takes
quite some time costs quite a lot of
money to develop a methodology that
crosses all the t's and dot Saul the
eyes and gets the approval of the United
Nations and you also need alongside
those methodologies performance
standards to assess whether people are
actually following the methodology in
the approved manner and delivering as
one hopes the desired ecosystem service
and I think there's a lot of focus on
methodologies and performance standards
because very often we can't see or feel
or touch the ecosystem service so you
don't really know for sure how many tons
of carbon have been pulled out of the
atmosphere all you know is that somebody
has planted a bunch of trees and so you
have to say well did they plant the
approved species in the approved
planting pattern following the approved
methodologies if so we can by inference
assume that those carbon that carbon was
in fact locked up in those trees in the
quantities that they claim and used I
think the same is true for many
watershed protection schemes that we
can't measure directly the watershed
benefits sometimes you can measure
changes in water quality and quantity
but often that's expensive and you can't
do it on a regular basis so what you
measure instead is the change in land
use realistic targets and caps and
timetables is a critical issue here
we've seen the failure in the carbon
market of people to negotiate realistic
it's and timetables and that can upset
the market because it will discourage
investors from getting involved it
creates extra volatility in pricing and
that scares people off there's a variety
of instruments that can stimulate
private investment it's not just one in
the carbon market we've seen incentives
for energy efficiency we've seen
technology standards to try and promote
less energy intensive goods and services
we've seen tax credits we've seen the
trading scheme itself so it's it's not
always just one mechanism that is going
to deliver what we want but there may be
many related market mechanisms and
they're not always consistent with each
other monitoring enforcement is a key
issue you may have heard about a year
ago I think some people stole a bunch of
carbon credits from an account in Europe
and resold them in another country and
that was because there wasn't really a
very tight control on the accounting of
those carbon credits if you're going to
be trading and intangible good or
ecosystem service you have need to have
very tight control over the registries
that keep track of trades what's being
traded make sure it isn't traded or dug
again and again and particularly with
respect to social impacts we need to
have an adaptive approach because we
don't always anticipate the unintended
consequences on certain communities of
the actions we take and we need to
somehow make adjustments and you can see
this very clearly in the case of the
Mexican p.s scheme where when people see
how the system is set up they start to
try and manipulate it to their maximum
advantage and therefore the government
changes the system and adapts it
year-on-year to try and improve it to
get the outcomes that they want in terms
environmental terms and in social terms
you can't just
have one system and and assume that it's
going to continue working forever and in
the same way people will start playing
with it as soon as it's a alive
notwithstanding all those caveats and
challenges of payments for ecosystem
services we've seen meant more and more
countries set them up and these are
largely government funded schemes and
contrary to what some people have said
in in recent years that oh this is just
for rich countries in fact many
developing countries are putting quite
substantial sums of money into payments
for ecosystem service schemes including
in China something like four billion
dollars a year going into the sloping
land conversion program which is
essentially an incentive scheme to try
and reduce deforestation on steeply
sloped land reduce erosion runoff
siltation and sedimentation downstream
and at the other end of the scale you
have some very small programs in in
countries like Bulgaria and Romania in
Ecuador and I think it's important to
recognize that you don't need to have a
you know a huge program you don't need
to be a government with tremendous
capacity things can be done locally at a
relatively small scale that are
effective I talked last time about
biodiversity offsets and I just want her
to make a few comments on the evolution
of that and the emergence of these
trading schemes for habitat or for
ecosystems I'm aware that there are
people in the room who know more about
this than I do but a lot of people have
been looking recently outs from outside
the US at the experience in this country
with wetland mitigation banking it's
become a kind of test case or pilot
project a lot of European governments in
particular see it as as an example of
what they they could be doing themselves
and not necessarily exactly the same
so for those who don't know this is a
program that was authorized back in the
UU 70s under the Clean Water Act but
didn't really get going until the end of
the 1980s and didn't attract major
investment private investment till the
90s I believe but essentially the idea
is that if you impact a wetland as
determined by the federal government
what is a wetland in the United States
you have to compensate for that impact
and in general that compensation has to
be in kind that is to say you need to
restore conserve wetland equivalent
wetland typically more area than what
you have impacted and generally within
the same watershed or so what they call
service area as the the impact and
because you can do it yourself but you
can also contract a third party to do it
we've seen over the last 20 years or so
the emergence of a very lively trade in
wetland mitigation credits from
entrepreneurs mostly private
entrepreneurs who have acquired land
restored wetlands on that land obtained
credits from the government and turned
around and sold those to to developers
it's worth pointing out that a lot of
the purchasing has been by government
agencies particularly the transport
companies transport agencies at in the
states when they're building new roads
widening them for example they might
have an impact on wetlands and they need
to compensate for that under the same
legislation the value of this market is
really hard to tell because it's an
incredibly untransfected my sense is
that if you want to get information on
the price of particular trades the price
of credits it's not something you can
look up on Bloomberg right and maybe
that's an indication that it's still a
relatively immature market in that it's
not a it's not a very transparent market
nevertheless people have tried to gather
information
on this market and also on similar
initiatives in other countries so you
can see the little dots on the on the
map I can't remember what the
distinction is between the white dots
and the dark dots but essentially they
refer to different versions of
biodiversity offsets and have a chat
trading I think if I'm not mistaken the
the habitat trading ones are the darker
dots that is to say those are countries
in which governments have either set up
or are in the process of setting up
trading schemes rather than just one-off
offset schemes and as you can see
there's a concentration of experience in
North America Europe and Australia and
I'm looking forward to learning about
the Australian experience when I get
there very soon ok I've sort of reached
the end of the material that's in the
tube for business report and what I've
prepared for these lectures and I just
wanted to very quickly recap what we've
covered and some conclusions from that
if I may firstly we looked a little bit
at what's the business case why would
businesses be interested in biodiversity
and ecosystem services we've looked at
how companies and can understand the
magnitude of their impacts positive and
negative or their dependence on
ecosystem services we looked at a range
of tools that businesses have developed
on their own or in partnership with
others to try and avoid or mitigate
biodiversity risks and we've looked at
some of the emerging business
opportunities the the positive or good
news where there's an alignment between
business value and environmental value
we've looked at some of the target
setting and other voluntary actions that
businesses can take and I should
supplement that by pointing out that
more and more businesses are interested
in getting involved in discussions about
regulatory reform and there are
particularly interested in these
market-based approaches because they can
see how that might be aligned better
with their own investment strategies and
we've looked a little bit at some of the
different types
regulatory reforms that are in place or
being put in place and I just want to
conclude with a couple of thoughts on
aligning market incentives with
biodiversity conservation and the first
is I suppose the obvious that markets do
not deal very well with intangible or
non market value so you somehow need to
find a way to make the intangible the
aesthetic the spiritual the cultural if
you're willing to into something more
tangible and well we don't always know
what the boundaries are of what's
appropriate to bring into the market
what's appropriate to commodify if you
don't do that the market will continue
to ignore it for the most part and you
can try and build a fence around it but
then you have enforcement issues and we
can see that in many cases the the power
of the market overwhelms the capacity of
governments to enforce constraints on
resource use I think we've also seen
from experience that while voluntary
market initiatives can work relatively
well they're not always sufficient so
you can attract a certain level of
business commitment through
certification schemes through voluntary
carbon markets and what have you
voluntary biodiversity offsets but if
you really want to get scale and the I
think the Europeans proved this with the
emissions trading scheme if you want to
get significant scale of investment in
these ecosystem markets you need a
regulatory mandatory scheme you need
relatively powerful market incentives
not just wishful thinking and those
incentives they can be designed in such
a ways to attract private investment
they can be business friendly they can
be market oriented and they include
information instruments such as
certification and labeling and but also
reporting and disclosure requirements
they include fiscal policy reforms
undoing so-called perverse subsidies
such as subsidies for land conversion in
some countries or subsidies to the oil
and gas industry but you can also use
carrots
tax credits or other payments for
ecosystem services to try and encourage
people to do the right thing and a
particularly powerful mechanism for
creating incentives for the private
sector is reform of property rights and
in and liability and I include the two
together markets are predicated on
private property rights they're
predicated on the notion that you can
exclude people from certain resources
you control those and you can use those
in certain ways I'm not a lawyer I'm not
an expert in in in tenure and liability
by any means but I think it's clear that
if we're going to make progress on
environmental markets we need much more
collaboration with the law community on
the the design or redesign of resource
tenure and environmental liability
schemes and i also want to leave you
with some conclusions on the the poverty
angle because i think it's hard to have
a discussion about ecosystem markets
anywhere in the world today without also
getting into a discussion about poverty
development equity and distribution and
i think the thing they do go together
even though we don't always have the
analytical tools or the evidence base to
really understand what are those
interactions but I think we can draw
some conclusions from experience to date
and that is that if you want to have a
positive impact on the poorer
communities and and more vulnerable
societies you need to focus your your
business action on the places where they
live the sectors in which poorer groups
work such as agriculture forestry
fisheries the factors of production that
they own that's basically their own
labor to some extent land the outputs
that they can produce which again are
often commodities the markets that they
can participate in and the costs that
they can afford and I think similarly
when we look at what strategies are
going to achieve more Pro poor outcomes
in terms of interventions whether it's
by development agencies or
businesses first and foremost its
governance in the rule of law and
there's there's limits to what business
can do there but I think without that
rule of law we're not going to get
equitable outcomes let alone
environmentally effective outcomes
access to information and services
reducing constraints is often an
effective mechanism and we've seen this
in many developing countries where if
you want for example to get involved in
charcoal production or in sustainable
wood production or in sustainable
agriculture they're all kinds of
regulations that make it difficult for
people to to do that bigger companies
can afford to get through those
regulatory schemes poor producers
small-scale producers find it very
difficult so we've seen in in carbon
markets for example the development of
so-called small scale or yeah small
scale methodologies to try and get
around this this constraint on the
regulatory constraint on participation
of the poor participation is sort of a
mantra in the environmental movement we
always need to try and improve the
extent to which marginalized groups can
take part in decision making a big part
of that is looking at not just global
priorities but also local environmental
concerns which may be more to do with
clean water water supply access to
agricultural land rather than some of
these global concerns that we have about
biodiversity or climate and promoting
sustainable use rather than simply
strict conservation can be a useful
strategy as well that's a lot to try and
boil down into a couple of slides and
thank you for bearing with me from on
that I've reached the end of my
contribution to this course I want to
leave you with a list of the people who
should have been up here with me and
might have been even more eloquent than
I but these are the people who
contributed to the teep for Business
Report among the many other hundreds of
people who contributed to other cheap
reports and I think they also deserve a
of applause so thank you very much it's
been a privilege and a pleasure